Нові приміщення, нові обличчя.
Оновлений склад Верховного суду України
заступає до роботи.
40-річний Володимир Бевзенко - один із нових суддів.
Це робочі місця суддів,
які в відкритому засіданні розглядатимуть справи.
Суддівство для Володимира Бевзенка -
абсолютно нова сфера діяльності.
Останні 16 років доктор юридичних наук працював
в університетах Херсона, Луцька та у Київському
Національному імені Шевченка. Вчив студентів,
яким має бути правосуддя . Тепер університетський
професор отримав шанс показати все це
на практиці й своїми знаннями принести
більше користі суспільству.
Амбіції, намагання самореалізуватися і
намагання принести себе в жертву суспільству,
скажімо так. Можливо, це дуже гостро звучить… Але служити суспільству.
Служити суспільству суддя Бевзенко буде
у виборчій палаті суду, тож розглядатиме
всі суперечки щодо виборів.
Також він виноситиме вердикт,  часто остаточний,
щодо правомірності дій держслужбовців
центральних і вищих органів влади. Це можуть бути
доволі гучні процеси, пов’язані з певним тиском
зацікавлених сторін, як це вже багато разів було
під час функціонування Верховного суду
старого формату. Але сенс судової реформи -
зламати корумповану систему, яка по суті своїй
не може ухвалювати об’єктивні рішення.
Стара система просто не здасться, це суддя
Бевзенко розуміє, але має для неї певний інструментарій.
Я бачу себе в тому, щоб бути професіоналом
і бути відповідальним, виправдати такі сподівання, які є.
Суддів Верховного суду обирали
на відкритому конкурсі. На 120 місць претендували
більше 600 кандидатів. При цьому враховували
навіть думку психологів. Ті, хто зміг подолати
усі етапи відбору, отримають дуже гарну зарплатню -
від 120 до 300  тисяч гривень. Аби не було спокуси
щодо корупційних дій.
Суддя Бевзенко зараз мешкає з родиною
в гуртожитку. Він готовий працювати 24 години
на добу 7 днів на тиждень, аби виправдати довіру.
виправдати довіру.
Буде тяжка титанічна праця. Вона буде невдячна,
тому що я так допускаю, що, можливо,
очевидного ефекту суспільство від нашої діяльності
одразу  не побачить.
Суддя Бевзенко прогнозує, що оцінити
ефективність нових суддів суспільство може
десь за два роки.
Адже спочатку вони мають розглянути
адміністративні справи, що залишилися
від старого складу суду ще з 2013 року,
а вже потім взятися за суперечки,
що виникають зараз.